one of the things that I thought was
fascinating that you looked at was the
use of human kissing what's the
explanation for that it's one of those
things for which there is never been
really a satisfactory explanation one of
the interesting things about kissing is
in mouth-to-mouth kissing I mean not all
cultures do it so it doesn't necessarily
work everywhere but it seems that it's
as close to a universal as anything
might be in the large numbers of
cultures the key to it is you're
exchanging information on essentially
your immune system so it's reckoned a
five minute hit results in the
transmission from one person to the
other of tens of billions bacteria and
all sorts of other things that belong to
your inside to the other person and it's
giving them a very direct measure of the
quality of your immune system so if you
think about falling in love courtship in
other words as a process of assessment
and at this point you can get a good
sniff of the other person there's
nothing important in humans very
important very important